ladies and gentlemen I have a momentous
bit of news for all of you I know I hope
everybody is sitting down because there
is something that happened last night on
the Tucker Carlson program that has
absolutely
rocked the Republican primary and is
completely changing the Dynamics Vivek
ramaswamy has announced that he is
entering the Republican primary
I know I know I'm giving everybody time
to react to this uh no one cares and
it's really really even Tucker Carlson
kind of seems not to care it's it's kind
of sad to be honest Vivek ramaswamy is
it
this is so stupid he's an anti-woke
entrepreneur and he founded last year
something called strive Asset Management
it's an asset management firm which on
its websites on its website says it
seeks to restore the voices of everyday
citizens
oh okay that sounds pretty pretty cool
so anyway here he is and it's just like
a deflated balloon
take a look at this on you know just a
cable hose but this is a perfect
illustration of where identity politics
wind up right when you stray from
Universal principles that bind us all
under the same rules exactly I mean we
are in the middle of this national
identity crisis Tucker where we have
celebrated our diversity and our
differences for so long yeah that we
forgot all of the ways we're really just
the same as Americans Bound by a common
set of ideals that set this nation into
motion 250 years ago whoa and that's
what I'm proud to say tonight that I'm
running for United States President wow
those ideals in this country those basic
rules of the road meritocracy the idea
that you get ahead in this country not
on the color of your skin but on the
content of your character right the idea
that you are allowed to speak freely yes
to be wrong sometimes as long as your
neighbor gets the same courtesy in
return yeah the people who elect to run
the government by the way are the people
who actually run the government basic
rules of the road these are the things
that bind us together you and I have
different different shades of melon you
know what I say so what you know I could
have sworn that he said different shades
of shades of melon
like you know uh
Tucker's more of a honeydew guy whereas
Vivek is really preferential to
cantaloupe but I I think what he's
saying is different shades of melanin
right like different skin color that's
not beautiful that is not our strength
our diversity is meaningless if there's
nothing greater that binds us together
across that diversity yeah and the
reason that I'm running for president is
to revive those ideals and I believe
deep in my bones they still exist that
most Americans still believe in them but
we need to ReDiscover that and the only
way we can do it is by start to talking
openly start talking openly again so I'm
not going to ask you yeah really a
momentous thing and then on Twitter
Vivek ramaswamy announced he will end
affirmative action tweeting quote as U.S
president as U.S president I will end
federally mandated affirmative action
full stop I will repeal Lyndon Johnson's
Executive Order 11246 which mandates
race-based quotas every Republican since
Johnson had the opportunity to do it
I'll do it on day one without apology
well he won't do it and it won't be day
one there will be no day one
um and there is just something funny
about you know in particular like when
somebody like this announces
do you think they know that this is a
joke
or do they actually sit somewhere and go
you never know I might be able to pull
this thing out I'm just not sure but a
very very big get as you can see for
Tucker Carlson getting this announcement
on his program and this certainly we
will have to spend some serious time
figuring out how this announcement from
ramaswamy
is going to completely upend the
Dynamics of the Republican primary so
stay with us for more on that maybe
someday if it becomes a real thing we're
going to take a quick break and much
more to discuss I'm very much glad
you're with us today